[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I keep forgetting that that just dropped
you right in then Janka what up are you
ready - I'm so ready for Halo Reach PC
[Music]
yeah we're we're sitting here with I
just okay yeah us wanted to build up
anyway hello everyone it's Tuesday
Tuesday it's Tuesday and we're here
playing Hillary for PC I can't win I'm
just gonna change my beanie that is done
change your beanie to something
non-committal dang I'll just rotate it
around or something yeah uh Halo Reach
on PC the days here we're playing it
it's live you can buy it you can have it
on your pc game pass very excited about
cross play all sorts of stuff yeah so I
just downloaded on Steam and it made me
put in so you can definitely play with
people who have it on the window F game
House ultimate you get that for free
free otherwise I don't know it's like
cross play we like Xbox I don't think
his cross play with ax but I get the
feeling that could be a thing coming in
the future about be really cool so
anyway here it is they've redesigned the
UI it's a lot better now
yeah it's just text before it was like
these dumb boxes that I'm like it's a
real menu anyway let's just get into the
game and then we're gonna we're gonna
kind of go from there
yeah
he reaches the only option they're gonna
slowly be rolling them out one at a time
and you can buy them either individually
or you could just buy like that bundle
version right now yeah so reaches by
itself like ten bucks right yes every
one of them is gonna be ten dollars
except for ODST which will be five
dollars there you go so if you want them
for a little bit cheaper you can buy
them all just quick starting to get into
it yeah whoo I love it
it's it's the best way to play this is
my first time playing with the PC
controls very excited to see how this is
gale stolove reach yeah
I also really like this idea of putting
it on a new platform like PC and then
slowly rolling them out in like an order
yeah I think that's cool I mean I think
it makes sense to like if rather than
waiting for it to all be ready they're
like hey reaches ready take that one out
that's the one people been wanting I
think it's a smart yeah why would he do
it I mean if you have been on xbox nk9
have them all yeah
hoopha story never played it crime it's
a good one
it's good one highly recommended I look
at all those frames yeah 60 frames a
second now mm-hmm it had an option for
unlimited frame so I could potentially
go higher than 16 I would love to see
how this works on my monitor at home
it does have an ultra-wide support as
well yeah there are a lot of good PC
options yeah they actually did a really
good job for mass at least it seems so
far yeah uh I can't help but just smile
I'm looking at it that's a great
question
so I heard some people saying it might
not but we can definitely check it out
we're here just to kind of poke around
and see what they're doing
even split-screen they just take it out
in fire teams which have since been
declared
m.i.a and now you're sending us the
Office of Naval Intelligence believed
this was also the first Halo game where
I felt like it looks seriously
impressive like to say the hey whenever
looks good but I guess ok halo 2 and 3
have a really bad faces yes especially
by the time they got to 3 and you're
like dude character models like alien
stuff looks good Chiefs armor looks good
like face oh my god what is happening
then this one they're like we will hire
artists really good faces great you see
all these cool armed armor permutation
are exclusive to each of the characters
you actually have them all single like
they're all knock like they were in the
original game - it looks like this is
what halo started to kind of veer
towards looking a little more like a
more realistic military look and I know
that some very controversial thing like
people really don't like how about we
looked at 4 and 5 I love it and this one
hello infinite
right - like 83 I like it in this one
because it feels like an invasion
yeah like the main commander guy of
course you'd have a bunch of pouches cuz
he has to like carry a whole bunch of
important stuff no this is a livestream
we're here to talk know also I I mean
this game is very old I don't know yeah
if you just wanted like see this game
increasing game out of you I can do that
here we go
one thing I never liked was the loading
screens at the Master Chief collection
at it because it kind of um kind of
broke some of the games listen up no
good team we're looking at it down relay
outpost 50 clicks from physical yeah
we're gonna introduce ourselves to
whoever took it out and then cats gonna
get it back online a chance maybe can
ask him George George is the best
commander we just lost our signal the HQ
backup channels
nada can't play with Jenny you heard her
dead zone confirmed command will not be
keeping us company this trip
do you know if you can pick any level
from the gecko like you came with
massive Koch and possibly Fox
what difficulty Ron run heroic otherwise
known as normal difficulty inhale oh
yeah it's a difficulty that these the
game should be playing what's that some
subtitles I can't wait for you to crank
up the field of view yeah I want to see
how it looks you're telling me it's not
subsidies kind of low yeah
that is the de-stress begin
do you like these settings
could be the missing troopers let's
check it out
this looks really sharp
this is a good firefight map yeah
let's go six okay terrible it works it
works I'm sorry Dave
what's hoppin the options here to see
what we got
like we can do complete 180 configure oh
that's excellent look at that Crouch
behavior
I like toggle on crouch zoom mode is
fine and held mask acceleration and okay
met sensitivity I'm gonna crank just
just a touch yes actually mostly good
smoothing I don't like on this is all
great I love this feel the view okay
start 78 you just gonna go right for 120
I'm like I'm like 90 or 100 when I go
otherwise these are options we have a 60
frames we've enhanced graphics on house
the mouse and keyboard from my playing a
little bit earlier it works pretty well
I still think I might play with a
controller just because that's how I do
it with Halo but they also have a
crosshair position originally it used to
not be exactly centered but they default
it out of centered I'm gonna keep it
centered hey yeah I love that they give
you the option to go back to like those
old settings if you prefer them oh the
sensitivity got like lower
highly cranked it up though then fov
looks not bad though yeah yeah how'd
that happen I like cranked it up three
sounds it sounds good at the high and I
files to put 360 for the fov so you can
just see through walls
so best armored ability what's what wins
your favorite and reach yeah I like
everyone's like oh man jetpack you can
let go vertically place I love sprint
too much
like I love their version of the assault
rifle brian says that apparently the gun
sound muffled I wasn't playing with
sound okay see if we can troubleshoot
this I mean it might just be the game
interesting of like options for Hillary
is not my master chief collection how do
I find the game on game Pass Xbox I
don't know if the console versions been
updated maybe it's possible I know that
the PC version is for playing it but do
not we could we tried
apparently the audio issues huh so weird
good thing check the store people are
saying check the store restart and get
that update for for your Xbox and it'll
moas
I'm so excited to play this again me too
and I do appreciate that it's inked all
my progress from my Xbox version to my
Steam copy yeah yeah throw on top of it
there on top of it I you know they they
I don't think they've been bringing it
with the game's generation but when it
comes to the advancements in like cross
play and like providing cool services
like gamepad yeah any more games Sean
Sean brings up that Halo Reach is only
available on PC right now but yeah
they're they're eventually going to roll
it out
oh there you go just like Derek says and
waves as they're ready I don't think we
have any release dates on anything else
one of the multiplayer features like I
assume like they usually are but we have
looked like I would looked at like the
hoppers they have available right now
but I'm sure that it will check it out
though didn't we turn on subtitles I was
gonna say am I crazy did we I thought we
turn on subtitles yes sometimes wrong
interesting
sorry guys subtitles are on so I guess
those subtitles only apply to may have
to select the language to tell it what
to do okay cancel that yeah
[Music]
maybe it'll pick up the subtitles only
apply it seems like a bit of an
oversight
well hmm that's strange oh they're only
in cutscenes okay great
I don't like that yeah I'm sorry guys
Microsoft or maybe the worst storefront
it's definitely not a good storefront
because it's it's also light therefore
yeah so if you want to download
solitaire or outer world as it Scott is
this on game pass yes if you have a PC
game passed or can't pass Altman's you
have this
oh man I'll let you going first
scary sounds let's go be a great
starting point yeah it's it's a very
good point to start off plenty of
swinging Alouette
it's the the wasn't that kind of sets it
all up don't know why blend the way I
guess is halo reach the exact Metal Gear
Solid 3 of Halo it's one of the better
games in the series it's a prequel like
there's some similarities there it may
be a bit of a stretched comparison but
I'm kind of here for it I personally I
think halo 2 is my favorite multiplayer
halo I think I played more 3/2 but I
think I think 2 is the one that like I
can still play just so excited is just
all this this reign in this game this is
setting you off sneezin cross play
between PC and Xbox I don't think
there's cross way between PC and Xbox
but there is cross play between Steam
and the Microsoft Store
future hearing people saying is the
top-selling game on Steam right now I
believe it I'm very excited that we're
all going to be playing Halo on PC in
2019 into 2020 that's my e to be fair
like it's sort of the same thing as like
the car bot I think that's like kinda
why but it can super combine and that's
the big thing yeah I like the carbine so
my favorite weapons someone just asked
what our favorite weapons were both
human and alien I think I like the
shotgun specifically and reach I like
how it looks
oh yeah the reach shotgun looks calm but
I love shotguns and Halo games they all
like feel really good use but if not
that then the battle rifle I love the
three-shot bursts um it feels good to
shoot I would say the only real
noticeable issues so far as the audio
yeah we're like the gun sound really
kind of muffled hopefully that's
something they think soon because I want
my good sound in Halo
over a hundred K people are playing on
Steam right now I'm is this free play No
ten bucks it's $10 to get reached by
itself or you can buy and that gives you
everything and I think it saves you some
money in the long run - I'll just get
that assassination on him oh yeah I
think it's holding down queue but he
says turn his front to you again it's
okay
use melee and then you put it down for
the assassination is is the first thing
it did some like I need I need to get my
cool assassination animations in
Eija Fuji's I enjoy halo this looks like
the 360 version oh if that's true you'd
probably play online I don't know if it
has split screen though yeah
that's how you can change the fov just
yeah I look that moment when George like
climbs on the back and then like mounts
his gun on the back of the girl a troll
now this this is good
rebels don't leave plasma burns I I
missed chapter names and Halo games I
mean like I miss because I haven't seen
it a long time yeah I got through it and
I was kind of like man Master Chief
collection though
again no split-screen seems like maybe
if it's not and now I hope they're
working on it because it's a big thing
for Halo also imagine playing these
games in split-screen at 60fps without
having to like give up your your field
of view or whatever I mean with the
performance that you get on a piece not
sure it's uh it's a weird one we're like
I don't know like they always just take
out split-screen out of games you know I
get that it's like not a thing people
most people will do but I'm always like
there's some people who want to do it
right and like I have to hold down so a
lot of people are saying it's kind of
like it like why would you even bother
with split-screen nowadays oh it's it's
just a thing that's big for Halo like a
lot of my vine memories for it are tied
to loved playing with my friends and
like locally is a thing I don't know
it's not necessarily a thing that I I
need but it would it's it feels like
it's a part of it
I know I'm no game designer so I don't
want to yeah yeah but my head I feel
like wouldn't it be easier to leave the
split screen in than to take it out yeah
but again
well it could be far more accomplished -
probably steam like two weeks ago put
out that playing local co-op games
online thing yeah it's like a there's
people who are still like looking for a
thing for that thing can you bind keys I
won't do that now but I'll definitely do
that when I play halo Master Chief she's
not a play anywhere title it it looks
like it it links up progress wise but
look at that shotgun but I don't I don't
think it's like cross play or anything
but play anywhere I think so is it it's
got all the stuff is this on games fast
PC yes yeah yeah you're you grab
birthday parties and stuff in there if
you want oh yeah yeah and also probably
the other ones sweet civilian trucks
George I'm coming
help pack oh I totally miss that help
back there probably be another one
you're fine you got shields
driving with the halo controls on the
keyboard and mouse seems like it's
probably the best way to do it it's
pretty good vehicle controls are always
weird with mouse or keyboard but yeah
there we go
we haven't tried multiplayer yet we're
like we just started where we're messing
around in the first mission we mess
around with the PC options a bit got
ourselves a new field view I only played
firefight a little bit before this I'll
get that assassination on
yes there is multiplayer online for this
this video game is forged for reach on
PC yes yes I think they are actually
working on getting old stuff transferred
over or something so like even if you
got like old stuff from the original
reach they're trying to like dig it out
look at them beautiful majestic
creatures we're gonna play infection
today could be a thing we hit up I don't
see why not
there it is the DMR
aw speed halo though I haven't played
speed halo and forever and by plate I
mean you kind of like just you kind of
let it go and it gets wild and out of
control but man all those custom game
types I'm so excited and I don't know if
we mentioned it but when you actually
launch the game on Steam it actually the
national launched two different versions
if you want to launch the with like
anti-cheat enabled or with it off so you
can do mods you could probably do local
stuff with it too or maybe it has
separate it has to have separate servers
because you can switch servers from xbox
to land I mean I wonderfully have like
modern servers maybe so they also said
that that right now is just sort of a
temporary fix and that they're they're
gonna add like official proper mod
tools' something and that that's just
sort of their current workaround so that
people can mess with mods but they said
that eventually they are going to have
what FPS are we getting yeah we got it
it's it's capped at 60 so we're rocking
at 60 right now I'm down for whatever
I'm just happy to be seeing the reach
right now we could check out what I'm
curious what multiplayer hoppers they've
got I got new on lock's
okay so you can just pick any mission
suite hello hit up the store base my
favorite just do that that uh that last
level and see see the chief
[Music]
do we want to check out okay so let's
see we have multiplayer you also have
firefights get all the usual stuff yes
that's how you get yeah if the armor
tears the reaches that's how they do it
is season points interesting okay let's
customize my my dude a little bit first
and then let's do some multiplayer yeah
yeah yeah you got to make sure your like
happens are looking good for it I wanted
to mess with my yeah here we go don't
think you have anything unlocked you do
color stuff yeah all all the stuff looks
like it's here though I I almost always
use ODST helmets that's the one but I
love that they have the actual like full
customization of the character I loved
this one yeah got some cool helmets on
this one change your body type you know
all these different elites you can be so
it I wonder if this is just because it's
reached but if they're going to come
back and give the full customization to
the other games to also had the
customization that was in the original
game so three doesn't Oh three you pick
full sets yeah you're right about that I
only know because I was like oh it's got
the Hayabusa stuff with the katana
unlock right there that thing that I
worked so hard for
there we go okay I just get myself some
quick colors yeah
okay so social games suis gosh this is
like they're just quickly getting this
is pretty good where you could just like
say I don't want to do yeah Grifball I'm
just looking at what they they got
competitive is more team hardcore and
reach invasion no invasion stuff
so they got to get Slayer flagon bomb
control asset denial
I mean grab bag Grifball regular they
got SWAT right there and everything's
good
why isn't why can you not pick the Oh
cuz it's blocked out 444 that's why yeah
I think someone in the chat nation
wanting it
let's do player cuz I you like I'm I
like it oldest player but it's a good
thing to warm up with how does this
matchmaking work though how good is it
that's the question oh I mean the Master
Chief question has gotten better and
better over time and there's a lot of
people playing this game on PC right now
this is great
excellent and it's already floating in
oh it's a forge map
aha we should probably be ready to turn
down the volume in case someone else
like their mic on our side but you know
I could go in it's it's good
what's invasion it's kind of like you
you have like a giant map there's 12
people on each team and you got to kind
of like do objectives to move further
into the map kind of like what's the
game mode in battlefield the one where
you have to like blow up the the the
things the like the boxes and then the
map moves forward it's kind of like it's
car like enemy territory you have like
an objective you've got to take down
doors this is good this is all good
this is everything I want this is it's
just it's just halo and it's back and
people are playing it rush there we go
thank you
ah it's been so long since I've like
fully played a battlefield game but yeah
kind of like rush whoa
does it look better now yeah it looks
better it runs better and it's got a
pretty big player base it seems and this
looks like it's it's staining other
people aren't dropping out yet
I'm very glad that everyone had my back
with that battlefield thing because I
felt like a complete idiot not referee
its I was gonna lose that fight see
ah it's definitely weird playing Halon
massive keyboard like there's certain
things to expect when you're playing
with a controller good like the Amos
it's like like you kind of you rely on
it the big thing for me is you're like
the way you play around it so not having
it is definitely the like not even the
aim assist for me but the big thing that
I feel is not having the controller
Rumble and it's weird how small it is
but it really messes with me also while
Paul jean-luc is in here doing this
multiplayer match other big things that
happened today man resident 3 remake
leaked on PSN I assume that's probably
gonna be like a game awards announcement
oh you know what my my most kills weapon
was in reach I'm out of turret yeah
because I would just walk around the map
because I like George so much I just
wanted to do like that that thing yeah
so most kills I had I'm pretty sure was
I'm out of turret rows at least really
high up
but yeah Rosie will 3 remake I don't
know if really another redesigns the
characters but I'm soaked do you have to
own the Master Chief collection to play
reach no so you can buy reach by itself
for 10 bucks I was like basically when
you buy the $10 version of reach you get
Master Chief collection and then you'll
have to buy each game as they come out
for $10 after that but you could also
just buy the whole thing for $40 and get
them as they happen
song and now I've got the collection
heck yeah jump in and get some sweet
halo action going I'm probably going to
be playing this as much as I can today
before our game of the year
deliberations which are happening I'm
very excited for that melee I'm it's
coolest want to go home and play already
your soaping you get out soonish I don't
know what time it is over where you are
but yeah oh and Rainbow six seats just
dang
there it is apparently Rainbow six siege
also went into its new season so if you
want to look for some good shooting game
stuff on PC or anywhere yeah yeah games
you got options I need to get back into
siege
I'm working I can't wait
set that's having these these releases
like this happen at a time when people
are doing working stuff it's should have
all just gotten the day off of work in
school because halos back yeah shipping
jus is a game running well no no
performance issues not that I've seen
and it looks like network performance is
good I don't think anyone's dropped yet
your press tab yeah everyone's still in
the game good and I haven't seen anyone
like kind of lag around and this is like
how long after release hour and a half
after release and there are like a
hundred thousand people playing and
everything is running pretty well
remember halo midnight releases I
remember going to midnight releases I
don't do it so much anymore though well
it's a weird thing because like yeah
west coast doesn't have midnight
releases so like I remember having to do
it back when I was on the East Coast and
now it's like I'll just pee order it and
have it downloaded and play it at 9:00
what's your favorite halo for me it's
it's got to be reach or two a lot of
three though now I think I think two
might be like two is my favorite
multiplayer but reach might be my
favorite overall package
you can't go wrong with three either I
like the deployables instead of like the
armored stuff it's kind of a good way to
do it where can i download anyone know
off of the Microsoft Store or on Steam
and you can get reached by itself for
ten bucks
or you can buy the whole match chief
collection for forty do try it I'm down
to say like give give a controller ago
are you putting a Playstation controller
what I hope it works what what if it
actually did like a button overlay oh I
think we might have gotten out of the
the game the sounds dropped out so it
might be hello it was like you can't Oh
what I unplugged it and the sound came
back uh we've got an thai police station
measures in place that's really on Xbox
controller right there do want to hand
me that oh yes do you have the is there
already a dongle in there oh that man
sounded very unhappy that he got hit in
the face as the framerate cap gets
capped at 60
it did feel really good that that one
hasn't been used very much yeah all
right
this works of course I think it's capped
at 60 at least for now oh you can never
mind that but I yeah I think they're
kind of like hey that might cause issues
try remember like okay with one of the
reach control this is each control do
they do they have like the universal
control schemes oh I think they do well
I'll tell you right now that I clicking
it on the stick it's not sprint I think
it's left bumper actually
it's X that's terrible that's not what
that button should do I think we have
vsync enabled so he it does it by
default so we're still missing you
plugged in a Playstation controller at
one point so don't do that yeah don't
you lose all your sound like that let me
check the settings I'd like to get I'd
like to get one of the like built the
non forged maps the camera looks lower
on the body on the PC version spurns
holy weapon a pirate that might be
because of the field of view you can you
can see like your other shoulder peeking
in now which is always great I love it I
do believe it is cross play with the
Microsoft version complete oh dude you
got your season rank up yah yah new
helmet you put it on unlimited FPS let's
let's slip in let's unleash the beast
see that what did it let it rip default
unlimited this is limited so we need
unlit go let it go all right we'll see
how that works also configure okay
Universal recon no I don't want that
I think reclaimer is the one that I'm
into cuz yeah I got the melee on the
right bumper so I can I can still shoot
an aim with everything so defaults yeah
what why would it someone was messing
with your account probably on an Xbox
thing must've like imported my account
so let's try default see how that works
but I do like that they let you do like
a universal thing across all the games
in the Master Chief collection
yeah oh you can see your friends Hey
that is I can invite them that's a long
clan tag hey bro let's play some halo
favorite Maps sorry countdowns on our
house our house is great
our house great flection hell yeah give
me back in that ivory tower oh my god I
love reflections sword base a Plus
zealot not as good as midship but still
pretty good anchor not bad oK you've got
some of these these are DLC maps yeah
yeah I played a fair amount of DLC
condemns pretty good battle Canyon heck
yeah all these are all the halo halo an
anniversary came with the multiplayer
for reach yeah so these are all like
that okay I don't like that is that's
that's difficult to do that's not great
I don't like that after like slowly do
it Ridge solitaire
High Noon High Noon yeah breakneck yeah
oh I love that it was such a good setup
okay well let's try another one how much
time for halo one I hope not too long
but I wish I could pick like Matt
preference like hey I don't want because
I remember getting really frustrated
with reach where it was like here's all
these Forge Matt so I'm like I kind of
don't want the fortune
oh maybe that's what happened
tens aru brings up the point that the
PlayStation changes your audio settings
so that the controller is got the audio
coming through that that could be a but
you still couldn't move with that let's
try it
Houston put on SWAT
yeah this should go a lot better now -
because you have the right controller
layout for your buttons
[Music]
they can release a new halo on PC every
two months until halo infinite that'd be
a pretty good way to do it yeah that's a
good point crime that's a good way to do
that it's a really good way to do it but
we're queuing up we're getting in there
[Music]
all right what map them again if maybe
you could like filter out just forge
maps or something I'd like that
I don't like yeah would they find a way
to put Halo 5 on PC then halo 5 Forge is
on PC
yeah yeah the multiplayer exists that
was a fun week where I like popped in
the halo official discord and you were
just joining like lobbies and like
matchmaking and playing Halo yeah it
makes me wonder if they'd have a plan to
do Halo 5 on PC at some point but I mean
not that I'd like play it much but I'm
just curious are you guys playing with
Xbox players online I don't I don't know
if it actually is cross play for you
there we go that's what is I did the
same thing with destiny like you like uh
FPS on on PC should always be played
with a mouse and keyboard until I play
destiny and I realize that I like it's
it's good but I play so much better with
it with a controller against other PC
players yeah it's like I'm used to the
way halophiles on a controller over
mouse and keyboard I could eventually
get used to the mouse and keyboard and
then maybe I'll be better with it right
yeah all right now all my muscle memory
is with this controller
like like the ice I'll keep think about
that the moment we were playing crucible
and I was like I'm just gonna plug in my
controller I can't they can't deal with
this and I ended up going like 32 in
five and I was like well I guess I'll
playing with a keyboard and mouse Oh God
all the way my controllers does do that
but hey it's still playing it's still
doing it just pc version so Fame assists
yes yeah that doesn't I mean Ryan like
it's it's like in your head you know
that it shouldn't be like that but I
just play so much better on the
controller and I I kind of don't like it
that's the situation for me
oh there's that scream tear yeah but we
got unlimited FPS that we can't see
because this monitor can't go past 60
and people in the chat won't be able to
see it either because
there's also something about firing with
the recoil cadence on a trigger that
yeah you're right like the vibrations
really is it there's something to it
that feeds back in in a real good way
what we need is we need rumble
compatible keyboards and mice will you
find a way to do that I bet you
someone's tried that and then they were
like this is done actually this is
ill-advised
yeah just on a 60 Hertz monitors like
that we don't really stream anything
higher than 60 FPS oh you have to move
monitors all around and stuff but yeah
this this isn't like like you know you
know coming to our stream room to be
like ah this is the best place to play
this video game no this is like here's
streaming optimized the flip and panic
grenades I don't know why he would do
that I'm going to switch settings back
because screen tears kind of
I don't think it has cross play with the
360 version now but they are however
importing all of the 360 custom Forge
maps that people made for halo yeah
three reach and four and they're going
to import them into the master
collection so if you ever have any old
custom maps and modes that you made that
you want to bring back through their
crime wants no I think they're on the
way but crime chromis know how our
stream is set up we have a two PC set up
yeah we have one PC that the game
another PC that streams out so don't get
any weird you see that Dylan's coming in
and asking the same that we're playing
on PC with a controller it's it's that
muscle memory it feels good on keyboard
and mouse yeah like don't don't get us
wrong
I would probably play
we're like a real weird like place if
like during the stream because it's like
ah we could play keyboard and mouse but
like died a whole bunch more
new items will be in forge that's
exciting to a we're gonna have a whole
bunch more people bringing in new maps
again to halo I'm so excited
I'll just playing what the controller
place you in lobbies and other
controller users are no I don't see any
indication for what people are using to
play like you kind of get in called
unique so it might not do that at least
not yet maybe that's the thing we look
at I think I can the fact that they've
been updating this so much I can see
them eventually being like and do that
in cross play I think they're gonna wait
until like the PC versions fully out
before they tackle that if I had to
guess and I don't want to like put words
in their mouth like yeah it's just that
is something that I can see them
I feel like wanting to do yeah they've
been very like open about what they're
planning on doing and they're also doing
a lot of listening to what people want I
mean this Halo Reach costs extra it
doesn't cost extra
but you can buy it separately I think it
cost extra oh never mind I'm not even
thinking about the I could be wrong was
like that guy right there maybe someone
in the chat can confirm for me but I
don't think you get it for free on xbox
if you own the game I think you get it
for free you must get it for free though
if you have game pass yeah cuz game pass
you just get the whole thing for free
yeah right yeah I don't know that's a
little weird not entirely sure how all
that works
yeah I keep forgetting that this is also
a thing for people who are playing on
console I'm just wrapped up in the fact
that we're playing on PC so what's on PC
that's crazy
we haven't had one of those since halo
Vista yeah right everyone loved halo
Vista I had to I actually got a bunch of
the achievements from it I also played a
whole bunch of the original Halo on PC
the flamethrower was the best thing if
you had a horrible connection I'll never
forget it yeah guys should stream Halo
Reach multiplayer matches with everyone
in the GameSpot office be cool to see
there's always been this thing in the
back of my head that's like what if we
all just like hook up a bunch of
original X boxes and yeah we just land
partied and our like at our desks or
something hi welcome to GameSpot here's
your desk and here's your complimentary
Xbox with copies of all the other games
boom you've got to show up for a match
post-lunch we'll see you there yeah it's
it's a thing I think would be a pretty
good time and there are a lot of people
in our office who love halo like most
people do so a good time not know it's
yeah I like I want to get good at it on
mouse and keyboard I think playing all
the muscle memories playing through the
campaign with mouse and keyboard to get
the muscle memory definitely that's
probably the way to do it
hello never died true but it did kind of
like it was waver a bit no don't be
that's jus boy it was it was thought to
be murdered but it was actually just
kind of knocked out and it kind of was
yeah but uh the three for three like
four and five aren't I like for its
campaign for their good games they're
just now kind of okay they're not what I
want from a healer I like for its
campaign it's not the best campaign but
I like it I like it story I did not I
did not care five multiplayer I thought
was better I think five has the worst
halo campaign yeah like straight up it's
not good yeah I still think if I were
given the option to like play any Halo
game it would probably like given the
choice I'd probably never pick four or
five I'd much rather play it's true I've
got options
how was halo two anniversaries
multiplayer I actually quite like the
anniversary yeah anniversary was good
Maps I like the way that feels
it's fun it doesn't feel like Halo 2
exactly but I think it feels like a nice
like halo 2 like but also modern I will
say without a doubt though my favorite
thing probably from 4 is the soundtrack
fourth got a very good sound for
soundtrack is very very high this is
pretty unmemorable afire I don't
remember anything about it what has a
very good soundtrack please sprint I
lost I somehow switch to Xbox app also
very heavy slush demanding I'm
downloading but also just running a
we're asleep on Steam so we're not
bought we didn't bobbed with the Xbox
stuff
double kill but it's the same experience
on both like if it makes you put in your
Xbox account so it's just that if you
have game past movies that version yep
kill three had a very good I think halo
2 might be my favorite halo soundtrack
halo 1 pill freezes good halo 3 is to be
fair a lot of like best remixes yeah
halo twos got that like the third song
that plays on the menu I forget what
it's called it's real sad yeah that like
get like having all your friends being
done playing multiplayer and you leave
the game running on your your screen
then you hear that you're like haha I'm
done for the day
this is sad firefight grunt pocalypse is
the best fire fight convinced me
otherwise fair ODST soundtrack is also
very very good oh oh yeah I was gonna
say the best thing about Hillier
soundtrack is Breaking Benjamin blow me
away
still audio issues outside of the gun
sounding muffled I don't bad no
noticeably bad Steam and xbox game pass
can play with each other yes yes it
makes you log into your Xbox account and
then it says your matchmaking through
Xbox Live so yes you can totally play
with other people who are playing game
Pass PC and yes it is free with game
path saltzman's except for the fact that
you're paying yeah it's always a good
thing it's free it's free but your
subscription paying for the thing yeah
sure also paying for a lot of other yeah
[Music]
also this bit of promotional art in the
background of this is really cool to you
you do not need an Xbox Live sub to play
the PC version now it just has to
connect to an Xbox account yeah it just
needs to connect to a Microsoft account
that's all so you if you don't have one
of those yet you'll have to make one but
you don't have to pay for a live
subscription
matchmaking for forge to be fair or not
for a fire fight like that would be the
one I would go to last I feel like I
wanna play campaign I wanna play
multiplayer
do you need a PC to play Master Chief
collection on PC uh I haven't heard if
that's the case but you might you might
need it
so it doesn't look like 360 progress is
transferred over but your progress in
the Master Chief collection on the Xbox
but you can still unlock all those
pieces of armor so it's plasma fight
it's still not as good as grown
apocalypse Master Chief collections
iPhone only see Master Chief collection
on PC to play Halo on PC with a PC pop I
think you might be right
I will have to like check the the
release notes to be sure but I think
you're onto it
does Halo Reach have playable elites yes
I'll just realize it also is pulling
your Xbox Live name for all your stuff
oh yeah thanks let Scott cool it's an
evasion bag yes
you need to be able to scale the weapon
models down yeah it'd be a nice option I
feel like this is a pretty like we've
got your field of view right now though
this is a good sweet spot yeah like this
is a nice comfortable you eye size for
can i play on stadia on my gameboy
advance I think that's something they
said they're working on but you've only
got to do it through WarioWare exactly
and then once once you have that set up
get your copy WarioWare DIY for the you
got to throw it all together
I don't we gotta figure out what's going
on with that microphone on that side
just apparently you're still kind of
quietly I might just be new pump you up
a little bit
pump me up I also talk quiet then I
think it is something with that
microphone though it it might be but it
is also definitely me because regardless
of what microphones and what situation I
am always quieter than everyone else
tank beats everything except for that
one well we do a review of the PC
version I don't think there's anything
in the works right now but
we're not people to ask about that yeah
PC and Xbox do not have cross-play said
they're allowing mods for each on a
zombie firefight with sword Spartans as
the enemy would be a good time I'm
curious how how crazy that mod stuff
will get there already some a pretty
pretty cool mod like overhauls people
are dying on their own with Halo over
the years so to have like and that's
with access to more limited tools so to
give people access to like here are just
all of the main Halo games go nuts like
that that's exciting because they just
have more to work with because a lot of
people have been like modding like a
gearbox version Halo one yeah but I
ain't got more to work with you come on
reach come on Halo 4 you can mod it will
free to use mouse and keyboard to play
Master Chief collection on Xbox I think
they're working on that it's there like
mouse and keyboard support is a thing
for Xbox well then they showed it off on
the the last inside Xbox ember okay then
okay so now it's the thing they've been
like talking about so maybe I don't know
now that how would that work with
matchmaking right as visual fidelity
better on PC or is limited by the
original textures no they actually have
an enhanced version
well not like an enhanced for like an
enhanced option so it looks a little bit
better but it's still this is still very
much the original textures this is a
port not a remaster yeah so it looks
pretty good though yeah I think the
game's art direction holds up very well
yeah I think if you were like expecting
like this gonna look like a 20-19
version of reefs like no no no no no
that's not what this is
they just ported the game brought it
over you get nice nice 1080p well more
than that and get to 4k
and then get up to 60 frames we I don't
think you could do split-screen no I'm
pretty sure we can
which is sad definitely but it's a buggy
I haven't experienced any bugs outside
of PE
yeah I haven't seen much outside like
literally the only issue is the audience
that's about it how big is the download
it was 15 gigs on Steam yeah on Steam
it's just reach it's 15 gigs yeah the
halo 1 port was kind of rough but it was
still a good time to play
I saw solid fun I but this is definitely
it seems like a pretty good mindful port
I never owned that port but I did have
the big free demo the demo that you
could play Blood Gulch on old yeah and
we just played that my friends would
download it in the what are we playing
on so right now we're playing on PC with
the mouse and keyboard and so looks like
it's doing pretty good yep do you need
Master Chief collection
if the either by the the 10 $10 version
that includes just reach which will it
gives you the Master Chief collection
but you want to access the other games
when they come back like Master Chief
collection is at this point more of a
wrapper yeah but you if you buy the
Master Chief collection you'll have
everything as it happens that's 40 bucks
honestly they should just add halo 5
yeah into it I was like man just make
the Master Chief collection like a halo
UI front yeah I think would be kind of
cool
can only run 60fps you can set it to uh
unlimited if you want you can we tried
that this monitor doesn't go higher than
sixty so we couldn't see a difference
but I'm curious to try at home see ya
thank you for playing this big fan
anytime Johnny we're also big fans we
love halo a lot being able to finally
play this on PC and there's a whole
bunch of people playing it again it's
real cool
who is this youtuber this is GameSpot
coms YouTube channel we're not like the
GameSpot we're not the GameSpot we're
just people who work here but we do a
whole bunch of game coverage GameSpot
mr. GameSpot we're not mr. GameSpot the
Bruce I miss fighting birds what's the
game spot it's the spot for games my guy
if you aren't familiar with us you
should check us out we do a whole bunch
of just we got we got reviews we got our
game of the your stuff going on right
now basically anything you want to know
about games we got it we do it playing
Halo a 20-19 do you recommend single buy
or do all the games
honestly I'd say go 40 and just get the
whole collection because I think in the
end if you buy them single single down
costing more yeah so that's if you're
like sure for a fact you want to and
also I kind of like doing my purchases
all up front so that later on when
they're like Halo 2 is out I can just
start up my game and it's there but if
you legitimately are like I only want
reach and I do not plan to buy any
others and yeah go for it but I
definitely plan on playing reach 1 2 3
ODST
I think you're missing one anyway I
think there's another Halo game I'll
play Halo 4 again I'll do I'll play
through it again but I playing playing
the other ones it's kind of what I'm
here that's the my yeah
just the constant hey is this a game
that you play after the high passes I
think there's always room in my heart
for halo oh yeah
it was the kind of thing where I would
just be like ah comfort game yeah let's
play some halo heck even was maybe like
a few months ago we were just playing
split-screen Halo in the speed zone here
at work like after everyone like after
we'd been done doing what we had to do
and it's still just fun like Halo is a
good game it's a good time
source happens there split-screen I
don't I don't think they're split screen
and the PC version I feel like it might
be a thing that we could consider adding
but I'm also not the people making the
game so I can't say that definitively
but as it stands there's no option for
it currently Sayla 5 coming PC of just
the Master Chief collection just the
Master Chief collection as it stands I
could see that happening eventually but
they have not said anything about that
who's your favorite Halo character and
why is it sergeant Johnson yeah sergeant
Johnson sergeant Johnson's a good dude
you're not wrong I love him he gets
killed in one of the games and comes
back again this wild character really
yeah and they like canonically like
found a reason to explain it in like the
halo novels again the the hug powered
him through the explosion
Cortana is a really good choice a good
character like her a lot
Miranda Keys is fine she does that
really cool thing where she like do
wields a shotgun and the needler yeah
I'm really into that that was real cool
before she dies kind of not cool
I kind of liked what they were doing
with the profit stuff in two and three
it felt a little more like he's just
evil like prophet of truth yeah we're
like two there is like a I don't know
I like the religious like they really
believed it kind of thing are you not I
love the arbiter talking about is it
isn't the the dr. Halsey the halls me
dr. Halsey
yeah well it's based on but it's cool
he's an [ __ ]
yeah but she's cool like that
yeah I'd say arbiter is probably my
favorite yeah oh so if you don't know
we're playing this is a mode called
firefight which is just kind of like a
wave survival thing yeah this is all
boring I can hop out you're you're
almost done with this else so the last
five guys are here we can move on oh
yeah firefights all here that just
jumped up in the air man have you all
read the knows I only read the fall of
reach which is a thing I kind of regret
I've read I read the three the one that
was Halo and then the one after that I
forget the names of those two I also
read a couple of I think I read a couple
the other ones as well first contact I
think I read I thought it was a listen I
was wrong
now this is the bonus round never mind
by crap you only got a minute left do it
we can we can hit up some infection I
think you want to do that next
as a possible play community maps and
game modes in the PC version yes so you
can and they're actually working on a
way to move the old ones from the
original game over into this one yeah so
like all the modes if people who spent a
lot of time making those they'll import
those over but in addition to that you
can just always recreate them yourself
it's true we need to provide Grifball
Grifball is an option in the settings i
think Rafal for a while I think I
eventually kind of got bored of it yeah
I think I like Grifball more when it was
kind of like slapped together and not
like an official an official like who's
the official Grifball map that they have
in like five or whatever and they're
like ah that's look this is too official
I liked when I was just that halo 3
Forge map that they yeah they turned
into an arena like you're in like the
middle of that container zone and
everything's blocked off and they had to
use like special like lights that were
actual like pickups Reese did you've
came with up with for fun and he's
everywhere and I keep me unlock some
shoutouts to achievements shout out to
achievements Grif falls pronounced with
the soft G dang I was an option to land
specifically yes there is well there you
go yeah I didn't see menu so there
totally is so if you go to settings and
you go to network you can switch from
Xbox to twin oh there you go
so there you go Juwan dual and that is
absolutely an option both go back to
xbox and we'll do infection
is it good yes I got I'm gonna say yes
infection baby I also like how this like
just taking all the different modes that
came from like people throwing things
together in custom games is really cool
like yeah I some of the best memories in
Halo 2 are playing infection and now
it's like an actual thing yeah only
split-screen seems to be the thing
that's missing what's your favorite
Slayer map or just like straight-up
Slayer I like every tell me I was gonna
say ivory tower is really good
midships good so that's I think that the
servers were getting hit really hard but
it everything's been going pretty well
people might just not be oh oh never
mind
we might just not be getting enough
people to do it infection might be the
issue I could give it an they're all
there playing spire Oh how many people
are online right now can anyone check
the player count I want to see I will
see if it's going used to just
straight-up tell you the player cow in
playlist here we go
and I missed that they don't do that
yeah cuz I made it like oh cool I know
I'm going to I love this map this is a
great mat it's also very good man said
you get this for Christmas back when he
played on the game on xbox barely we got
to play multiplayer because the
subscription on Xbox yeah yeah there
were a lot of people who played a lot of
Halo but couldn't play on online I
remember this was the map that was a
part of the beta I mean my friends
played it over the weekend yeah and my
friend couldn't remember what the DMR
was called so he called it the nad bar
at one point
oh and that just stuck so we just called
it the NAD barbecues
look at that water oh yeah and you could
add like a little like
[Music]
stop so cool so what was the thing with
alpha zombies I don't know if I remember
right but I think like the first the
first one is stronger than other ones do
yeah the first one is stronger I
distracted you that scam terrible at uh
infection anyway so good we've got some
nice kind of environmental touches
things falling over I like it
whoa 130 heck yeah
thousand people dang it whoa can you
vote for a maps or no I know they took
out map voting as a thing it was it cuz
a dang people who would always just vote
for Hill three Maps
yeah collection so I think they took out
Matt voting
I remember they like we redid a lot of
that stuff to try and like curb that cuz
it was now instead you can just kind of
pick more what you uh what you want and
do it that way I think it's a better
system yeah you get to see more of this
stuff well just be frustrating really I
really just wanna play some halo two
maps and they'd be like not today not
today man you're playing Halo 3 mansion
you like playing on the pit we playing
on the pit the whole time oh god I don't
like it's okay there's a good kind of a
loop there I got one that's okay keep
playing co-op via LAN you should be able
to can't see why not fiction you cannot
cross play with Xbox nope what about
input lag on mouse and keyboard I don't
think there is I haven't experienced any
noticeable input lag
you ever messed with a making Mishima a
little bit yeah it there's always that
part of me a long time ago that yeah
you're you came from like a similar spot
so you know we're kind of coming from as
we talked about like frag videos and
stuff but like yeah I wanted to make
frag videos or PvP videos or machinima
videos and it's always been a thing that
I've been into I've never been good
enough to make like skill videos instead
I wouldn't do you like my [ __ ] my stuff
no you teammates didn't have your back
means I get to have theirs now that's
the I remember that hill it's like you
just stand here the whole time and then
basically you just kind of wait til you
have enough people we we almost mess
around with the idea of making a
machinima type video a little while ago
yeah what if what if we did just get
like a machinima thing together
like what when when there isn't too much
going on and we just have like a silly
thing we can do this would have been a
good a good opportunity what if we make
the new red vs. blue they still make
that you know what if we make a new one
a better one I haven't watched
reversibly in a very long time I haven't
either and I guarantee that what we what
we do probably wouldn't be as we should
team up with hygiene to make machinima
alright I'm down
yeah we'll do red vs. blue but it'll be
orange versus red I feel like that's our
main our main color right is orange yeah
yeah
is it that guy on the hill nope
RB and the chief is the thing I haven't
thought about in a long time yeah oh man
I uh found that dude on on Twitter
recently what because I was just like oh
yeah that's the guy who made our being
the chief that dudes still tweets about
halo dang I'm like this halo stole his
brand yeah yeah it is keep on keepin on
dude
but real talk though we probably should
like not if it's not like mission mode
just do more stuff with IGN I like doing
that we did that that hitman challenge
was a very good time
hey you do a lot of that kind of stuff
yeah that that moment of like hesitation
realization really just turned around
and like oh yeah I messed up really so
like that cool down we're just new yeah
I you know yeah I wonder sometimes what
is a pretty cool thing okay would you
like to make machinima with man honestly
this would have been a fun one to do so
easy I used to mess with half-life ya
half-life's got some good stuff in it
you could do some real real like easy
silly stuff in VR because you're
actually able to act in it now a
terrible name
little cringy name now but there used to
be a counter-strike you shouldn't I
called leet world that was really good
oh the name the name is definitely like
it was cold but yeah yeah cuz just the
word leet now makes me like but uh that
actual show is very good too I'm not
even afraid to like admit that I bought
into that stuff like oh yeah I get to
it's just more like yeah that I like
that the number four people playing on
Steam is just going up and that the
thing is that's just steam is there's
people who are playing with game pass on
PC that we don't even know about what do
you want ended on act action sack I like
to try and yeah it's like the one Halo
Reach thing we haven't tried yet
we need Joe Joe memes made and reach up
you see crime those are all words that I
love
let's just let's just do Jojo machinima
in Halo Reach okay I'm down yeah that
sounds great oh man I didn't play much
invasion like I I played it to play it
originally saw it got it and didn't like
it wasn't my main thing that I kind of
came to what do you have winter hats on
are inside yeah that's just our thing
yeah at this point I like hats like
beanie oh it's it's because we're in
though weird winter months in San
Francisco where it's kind of cold and
also I haven't done anything to my hair
today
it looks real gross yeah this was like a
roll yes so you're you're playing as
elites and you're storming the this like
ship graveyard I forget the exact setup
for it but you've got to get in and
interact with these computer things to
turn off the shields to get in
oh this role are all the games in the
collection multiplayer they should be
mm-hmm
right now the only game on PC in the
collection is reach all the other one
should work if you're playing on xbox ya
Beck's box you can play them all but
there you go
if you're playing PC got away a little
bit I just hide there oh I saw that I
saw opportunities turning his back a
little bit yes this is the map is based
on all the second or last level yeah
what works best in Halo Reach PC keyword
master just controller uh right now we
seem to kind of be at a point where
muscle memory is better for us on
controller life yeah but keyboard and
mouse is a good option and probably just
needs a little more practice with yeah I
mean I don't think it feels bad it smart
to stay yeah muscle memory cross play at
launch you can play between Windows
Store and steam but you can't play with
Xbox
yeah both both control options work very
Oh save you I can't believe oh I got gum
tried he tried dang how do I believe
this game's ten years old yeah I still
it still holds up really well it still
feels really good to play hello
sometimes just gotta throw a grenade you
know
as a remaster just ported it's it's kind
of like a it's just a part it's it's
like a poor but they put some work into
it like it's not a remastered by any
yeah any sort of reason mate or not a
remake phrasing yeah yeah words like
that so confusing they did not do extra
graphical work I've seen some people be
like oh this looks like a ten-year-old
game oh my cats cuz it is yeah yeah the
mobbing stuff is gonna be wild that's
the part not excited about what they did
there's like an enhanced graphics option
which like brings up the resolution
probably on some of the stuff but it's
not like a full remake yeah it's a port
that has been touched up high-resolution
entire frame raves also I think there
are people who are confused we're not
IGN that a lot and I I assume it's just
people trolling but yeah sometimes it's
you see it pop up enough like a few
times in a row and I feel like I just
got to be like a just a heads up
there it is we're all the same now
that's fair
it's a giant giant lump of the games
coverage yeah it does kind of make sense
but it is good to kind of remind people
I guess you know like eh no worries
then you need access to more classes as
you go to okay it's all kinda remember
that being a thing am I just thought
like the maps are so large the amount of
players were so small it felt like it
was interesting but the potential is
like limited yeah $40 for all the Halo
games is it's a lot that's it's it's a
very good deal oh yeah a video game
podcast this Friday there should be a
podcast it's Friday I haven't broken the
record yet or our streak podcast streak
podcast a fun time what how Jake's gonna
do it for the vacation just double
record yeah is he gonna like do a double
record be fun yeah yeah holiday special
exactly holidays look the type of
holiday special where people just keep
coming in through the door and then
everyone has to stop and clap those are
my favorites
one will the rest of the Halo games be
available don't have any updates yet but
the idea of releasing them was crime I
think mentioned it earlier they really
said every like every two months leading
up to five or not five to infinite no no
it's five that's the would be a really
cool way to do it thanks for streaming
I'm a work so I can't play yet it's
downloading looks so fun I'm excited for
tonight when everyone's able to get home
and play again there's just somethin oh
hey lit halos got like this it just
feels good to be around and talk to
people likes people who like halo just
all seem like they're all happy I don't
know it's halo makes me happy it's I
can't put it your words cuz I'm not like
a writer at all or a person who does
words but halo makes me happy and seeing
people happy about halo also makes me
happy
how's the accuracy of a mouse good it's
just that weird adjustment to it yeah
you look like you're kind of kind of
getting in there with it
it
this isn't the the games yeah reaches is
out on PC right now hey I can get the
sword yeah
how's it sound the only thing I've I've
noticed is the the weapons sounding
muffle when you shoot him that's about
it I see I've seen some other people
talk about other issues I don't think
we've run into them ourselves nope
haven't really had any matchmaking
issues comfortable saying it's kind of
weird but yeah so far it's been pretty
good for us oh yeah I can create this
like a little hologram dude yeah
how the frame rates solid I haven't seen
it dip once a lot of them many friends
there are so many frames here we can
actually play you can actually play
we're playing right now we're playing
online with other people who pick the
game up it's $10 if you want to buy
reach by itself $40 for the whole
collection but you only have reach
available now unless you're playing on
console which you have everything and if
you have game pass ultimate on PC Oh get
it for free with it
got the I'm love it I appreciate these
these updates on the player account
that's it's also making me very happy is
the motion blur back I don't see it I
think we might be motion blur might be
out yeah got him and you right back
where you were basically you can set the
frame rate to be unlimited
we haven't locked at sixty right now
just because the monitor can't do
anything more than that also if we we
don't really stream more than sixty
because it's it's a lot put that shield
down no I'm just gonna put the shield up
and die I forgot how it works it's just
the [ __ ] from free
you can get above sixty yeah unlimited
theoretically infinite frames frames
tail infant and for halo infinite frames
[ __ ] man try to arm a lot it took me the
problem is you need to like coordinate
with your teammates and be like everyone
go feeling winded yeah man I won't talk
about her sixty Hertz monitor it's
because when we stream you don't we
don't straight a higher than seven sixty
so there's no point in like it literally
wouldn't do anything like so there's no
point because we have to cap it at sixty
anyway for the stream at home plan a
nice stops given my comments we're not
we're not trying to intentionally skip
anyone's comments is there a text
written game not Lee I didn't see
anything in matchmaking but at the menu
there is like a group chat box so I
think for like coordinating like party
stuff you can use like a chat box in
chat oh no there totally is
oh heck yeah it just popped up cool
alright well then they go there totally
is in-game chat
all right well I think we're gonna call
it there yeah yeah it is wonderful yeah
well we need to we gotta go we got
things to do and fortunately some yeah
we got game of the years to discuss yep
yeah once you hop on over to the main
screen and then go for joining us today
on this live stream we played halo reach
on peace it's us this is really cool I'm
excited to play this game again yes big
same especially now that like most of
the the big games are out and I can kind
of like just focus on what I want to
play yeah I'm very excited about that
me too so yeah if you're interested in
this you can pick it up on Steam for 10
bucks if you want to just play Halo
Reach or you pick it up for 40 if you
want the whole thing otherwise you can
it's also available on Xbox you on the
Master Chief collection and if you have
game paths it's all included it's
included that's pretty cool exactly and
you guys should be here tomorrow you
don't want to miss the stream that's
happening we're playing you should tell
him we're playing Nancy Drew the the
steams
top selling a top selling stub zones
team game Nancy Drew midnight in Salem
the long-awaited 33rd Nancy Drew
adventure games so please don't miss the
33rd Nancy Drew game released on Steam
top seller tomorrow same time same place
please don't go anywhere
if Roger guys uh yeah thanks for hanging
out we'll see you later
[Music]